dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here
today we are going to talk about the
material point method this method uses
both grids and particles to simulate the
movement of snow dripping honey
interactions of granular solids and a
lot of other really cool phenomena on
our computers this can be used for
instance in the movie industry to
simulate what a CD would look like if it
were flooded however it has its own
limitations which you will hear more
about in a moment
this paper showcases really cool
improvements to this technique for
instance it enables to run these
simulations twice as fast and can
simulate new phenomena that were
previously not supported by the material
point method one is the simulation of
complex thin boundaries that enables us
to cut things so in this video expect
lots of virtual characters to get
dismembered I think this might be the
only channel on YouTube where we can say
this and celebrate it as an amazing
scientific discovery and the other key
improvement of this paper is introducing
to wake up link which means the example
that you see here as the water changes
the movement of the wheel but the wheel
also changes with the movement of the
water it is also demonstrated quite
aptly here by this elasto-plastic jell-o
scene in which we can throw in a bunch
of blocks of different densities and it
is simulated beautifully here how they
sink into the jello deeper and deeper as
a result here you see a real robot
running around in a granular medium
and here we have a simulation of the
same phenomenon and can marvel at how
close the result is to what would happen
in real life another selling point of
this method is that this is easy to
implement which is demonstrated here and
what you see here is the essence of this
algorithm implemented in 88 lines of
code Wow
now these methods still take a while as
there is a lot of deformations and
movements to compute and we can only
advance time in very small steps and as
a result the speed of such simulations
is measured not in frames per second but
in seconds per frame these are the kinds
of simulations that we like to leave on
the machine over night if you want to
see something that is done with a
remarkable amount of love and care
please read this paper and I don't know
if you have heard about this framework
called Taichi this contains
implementations for many amazing papers
in computer graphics lots of paper
implementations on animation light
transport simulations you name it a
total of more than 40 papers are
implemented there and I was thinking
this is really amazing
I wonder which group made this then I
noticed it was written by one person and
that person is yuan Ming who the
scientist who is the lead author of this
paper this is insanity thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time